your wife tweeted that she's really sick
of you playing bejeweled all the time
she says that all you do is play
bejeweled she tweeted that out and that
it's actually become kind of a problem
well and don't you sound like a fool you
know because it's not it's not bejeweled
okay and this is for you too honey it's
not bejeweled and you know that this is
the best way for you to communicate with
your wife on television talk show
talking into account I mean she's
tweeting about it and telling the whole
world I you know I'm playing bejeweled
it's it's it's Marvel Puzzle Quest okay
it's Marvel puzzle quest and I
understand that the format's
of the game are similar but it bejeweled
is for like you know thirteen-year-old
little girls Marvel Puzzle Quest is for
men okay okay I have a still a screen
grab of both games side by side there's
puzzle quest and there's bejeweled they
look identical to me they look exactly
the same what's the difference dammit
man like okay they're both brightly
colored jewels no did you just tell me
to shut up
those are obviously power orbs on the
left okay now our orbs that win broken
engagement hours to help you fight and
kill soldiers look that guy has a gun up
there those are jewels and maybe I'll
give you gems because you know Thanos
and the Infinity Gauntlet they have gems
in them but there are no jewels
represented on that screen here a
bejeweled guide that he is he you are
you're all at a video game I just like
being bejeweled and I'm sorry I told you
to shut up
no no no I think you know what I think I
had it coming confusing the two gasps
yeah I got way out of line and so I
think I let's shake it out right now bro
I love you I love you you know I love I
don't really love you I love you
sweetheart
I love you I dunno that's over